good morning believe nation today's
message is look beyond rules over you
Nicholas Cage try to see myself as
somebody that is interested in extremes
that is interested in in maybe breaking
boundaries in terms of what is
considered acceptable or not acceptable
to do I I don't like the idea of rules
in art I once said along one play you
don't find a lot of rules yeah and I
once said I think in a magazine that to
be a good actor you have to be something
of a criminal
of course they took that as like I
wanted to be a criminal which isn't true
I just I just think that you you need to
look beyond rules I think this is really
really really really really important
you need to understand that wools are
created for people who have
below-average skills at something if you
think about a classroom that you went to
maybe you went to university to college
or high school and you're sitting in the
class you got 20 50 100 500 people
sitting there with you the material is
designed to teach the below average
person at that skill set right it's
designed so that almost everybody can
get it and as a result the pace is so
slow that if you're really good at that
stuff you're bored and a lot of you
who've been through those classes know
what I'm talking about where if you went
and talked to the professor the teacher
the person who's teaching the material
and you sat down with them for an hour
you'd learn way way way way more because
it's customized to you and the same
principle applies to your life and it
applies to your business understand that
most of the rules that you're paying
attention to in your life and your
business were designed for the below
average person at that skill and if all
you do is follow the rules follow the
way that everybody else does it you're
gonna have a below-average experience if
you just sell the same product for the
same price
and you do the same marketing have the
same website if you're just copying
somebody else and just following the
rules you're gonna have a below-average
experience where you need to do where
that example of talking to the professor
where you customize the experience you
need to apply that same principle to
your life and your business as well you
need to think how do I customize my life
and my business to make it suit me so I
can have the greatest value and the
greatest impact on the people around me
on my customers on my community on the
world you need to figure out ways to
customize what you do so that it fits
you your unique talents your unique
gifts and you can't do it by following
the rules if you look at every
successful business in history go look
them up whoever you look up to whatever
the company is that you look up to
whatever entrepreneur it is that you
look up to they did not follow the rules
they did things in their own way and
they pain a new path instead of being a
sheep and following the existing path
that's what you need to do for yourself
you cannot bring yourself down to the
below average standards now that doesn't
mean you have to go and break all the
rules write some rules you know you're
gonna get in trouble if you break right
if you are speeding you're gonna get a
ticket you got to deal with that there
are other rules that have much bigger
consequences as well but very few of the
rules that you currently feel are
important actually are and what you need
to do is think about how do I take my
genius my talent what I'm really really
good at and apply that to this industry
in a way that's never been done before
all these people are out selling it this
way this is how they market does how
these cells is how they promote if
you're not good at that
if that's not driving you if you can't
be the best in the world at that forget
that who cares that it works in that
industry who cares that that's to
tradition the way everybody else is
selling let them play out here you're
gonna come over here you're gonna do
this thing that only you can do that you
can be the best in the world that that
get people excited about that nobody's
ever done before that's what you're
gonna do that's how you're gonna stand
out that's how you're gonna win
customers that's how you're gonna feel
happy that's how you're gonna feel
fulfilled it's by being you bringing
your genius your talent your
abilities your excitement your passion
to your industry in a way that's never
been done before you have to do it if
you want to stand out you have to do it
if you want to have a big impact
you can't just follow the rules rules
are great guidelines to start with it's
good to know in general how something is
working it's good to know where some of
the penalties are but don't let that
shackle you and that this is the only
way to do it you need to understand and
then go out and do your own thing this
is why I love modeling success because
when you model success when you look at
people in a different industry look at
any entrepreneur you looked up to if you
are in the car business
you can go learn from a Steve Jobs or
Oprah Winfrey or Martha Stewart somebody
who's totally outside the industry you
could take something that worked for
Howard Schultz who started Starbucks and
apply it to your chair manufacturing
business in a way that's nobody's ever
done it before
and it feels like you this you're this
pioneer trailblazer breaking all the
rules where it's just learning from
somebody else who's done it in a
different industry but you're not gonna
have success as a chair manufacturer
doing what all the other chair
manufacturers are doing it's not gonna
work you're gonna end up with below
average results customize your life and
your business to the genius that you
have inside express yourself
let it come out let it fulfill you let
your audience feel it let your customers
feel it let the media feel it that's
where your success is gonna come from
financial success emotional success
personal success that's where it's gonna
come from stop paying attention to the
rules as Steve Jobs famously said you'll
discover at some point that the rules
were designed by people who are no
smarter than you and so why are you
living your life running your business
according to other people's expectations
according to what other people say you
need to do instead of letting this gift
this art come out and dominate so the
question of the day today is I want to
know what are the rules that you're
breaking in your industry or in your
life super curious to find out leaving
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to sherry from office
book.com sherry thank you so much you're
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
vessel so over the past few months have
been getting a lot of comments on my
videos and people asking me am I related
to Nicolas Cage I look a lot like
Nicolas Cage and to me this is just
totally ridiculous because everybody
looks like Nicolas Cage and I have to
proof to back it up pregnant women look
like Nicolas Cage your ribcage looks
like Nicolas Cage et looks like Nicolas
Cage Gandalf
Yoda Hillary Clinton Little Mermaid Mona
Lisa
Bill Clinton Albert Einstein the Statue
of Liberty biggie Buzz Lightyear
Princess Leia the Green Lantern Miley
Cyrus Barack Obama everybody looks like
Nicolas Cage I don't know why you guys
would say that but I'm deeply hurt I'm
taking names and I'm gonna remember who
you are